- Hello, everyone.
I am not Sal.
Unfortunately, Sal's a little
bit under the weather today.
I am Kristen DiCerbo,
the chief learning
officer at Khan Academy.
And I'm gonna attempt to fill
a little bit of his shoes today.
We are excited to have
as our homeroom guest,
psychologist, New York
Times bestselling author,
and monthly columnist, Lisa Damour.
And she'll be talking to us
about the emotional wellbeing
of our students in these COVID times.
So we're looking forward to that.
Before we get started,
I want to remind you
that Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit organization
and we do depend on donations
to keep us all going.
If you would like to donate,
you can go to khanacademy.org/donate.
And I know that this is
a tough time for folks,
but $10 even helps contribute
to keeping all of these
resources up and going
for folks that need it during this time.
So thank you, if you can do that.
I also want to recognize
some corporate folks
who have stepped up,
particularly in these COVID times.
They've been partners with us
and really helped make sure
we can keep things running.
That includes google.org,
AT&T, Fastly, Bank of
America and Novartis.
Thank you to them for
helping to contribute
to keep everyone learning
as we're going through these times.
So with that, let me
introduce Dr. Lisa Damour.
Thanks for being with us today.
- Thanks for having me.
I'm delighted to be here.
- Excellent.
So just this morning,
you published a column
that speaks to teenagers with your advice
about how to navigate
some of this time we're living in.
Can you share with us some
of the advice that you have?
- Sure.
So in my September column
for the New York Times,
I had written a, or actually
was my August column.
I had written a back to
school wellbeing checklist
for parents with regard to their
adolescent's mental health.
And in the comments,
several teenagers said,
why don't you just write to us
about what we need to
know about ourselves?
And I thought as usual,
the teenagers are right.
As usual, they're like
totally on the money.
My editor, who's
wonderful, was in agreement
that I could write this column to them.
So this one is called, dear teenagers,
here's what you can do to manage
your own emotional wellbeing.
And I talk through what
we know in psychology
about how adolescents, in particular,
operate when it comes to their feelings,
some of the super powers they have.
For example, they feel
things more intensely,
which we know this means
they feel difficult
and painful things more intensely.
It also means they feel pleasures
and joys more intensely.
And so at this time when
we are all, at this point,
kind of limited to small delights,
that pumpkin spice latte goes
further for a 16-year-old
than it does for a 30-year-old.
And that's a good thing that
they can take advantage of.
And I talk with about basic
mental health maintenance
and what to do when they're worried
and how psychological defenses work.
But it was, I will say
I've written that column
for five years.
I've written for the Times for seven.
I think this was my favorite column
I've ever gotten to write.
- That is great.
And I am sure that the teenagers
appreciate you talking to them
because knowing teenagers,
they're thinking I can do this myself.
I don't need the help of my
parents to navigate this.
So thinking about parents though,
what kinds of things should
parents be looking out for
in terms of signs that their
kids might be struggling
or need some extra help?
- Oof, this is such a hard time.
And the baseline we're starting from
is one of kids being pretty upset
and pretty distressed and rightly so.
We are also starting from a baseline
of parents being pretty
worn thin and pretty tired
and dealing with their own
stresses and anxieties.
And I think in that context,
it can be very hard to know
when it's time to worry.
Is the kid overreacting?
Is the parent overreacting?
So to start at the extremes
and then to walk it back.
We worry when a kid's
mood gets stuck in a rut.
So we fully expect the
normal adolescent mood
will go up and down.
You know, that they'll
be really salty one day
and then perfectly fine later
that day or the next day.
That's normal development.
We worry if a young person becomes down
and stays down, is sad,
lethargic, unhappy, low
for days at a time,
that's grounds for concern, or irritable.
At every opportunity, I
take it to let people know
that one of the forms
that depression can take in
teenagers is irritability.
It's sort of unique to adolescents.
And sometimes it's easy to
miss that they're depressed
because an irritable teenager is,
we can just dismiss it
as a snarky teenager,
but any teenager who is
annoyed with their parents,
annoyed with their teachers,
annoyed with their coaches,
can't stand any of their
peers, that is something
that should be considered
possibly depression.
And we worry about anxiety.
That it is too big,
meaning out of proportion to
what's going on or persistent,
even when things are okay or okay enough.
So that's when the worry, worry.
And what I would want parents to do
is to reach out to a
mental health clinician
or call their pediatrician even,
just to check in and sort
of get a take on things.
But then there's a lot below that,
a lot that's less concerning than that,
that's much more in the garden variety
of day to day raising teenagers
or pandemic raising teenagers.
- Can you tell us some of the strategies
that parents who have kids
who haven't probably
reached that threshold yet,
but are just struggling a little bit.
What are some things that they can do?
Well, a lot of it means just
allowing teenagers to vent.
So one thing that is true about teenagers
is that they complain about school.
And they complained about school
all last year school year,
not just this school year.
It's part of how teenagers do school.
And what I mean is they're
wonderful at school.
Teenagers hold it together
all school day long,
put up with all sorts of
hassles and annoyances,
are charming through the whole thing.
And part of how they do it is they collect
what I call their emotional trash
over the course of the day,
and then they get home and
they dump it on their parents.
And this is a normal and
expectable transaction.
Works really well for the teenager
because they tend to feel greatly relieved
after this transaction.
Is hard on the parents,
'cause they can sometimes
feel burdened by it,
but under normal conditions
and then pandemic conditions,
one thing that's really
helpful for parents to say
when kids are having a hard time
or feeling full of complaints is to say,
do you want my help with this
or do you just need to vent?
And so often teenagers
and tweens will say,
I just need to vent.
And then the parent can just let them vent
and know that they're serving basically
a functional trash disposal service
that lets the kiddo move forward.
The trick in the pandemic
is to try to measure
how much more they're complaining
this year than last year,
because they are.
But what I think is important
for parents to do is to think,
okay, on September 29th, 2019,
how much was my kid complaining?
How far above that increment are we?
The other thing I want
parents to be mindful of
is that we're hearing
more complaints sometimes
because we're standing right
there as school is happening.
And so, under normal conditions,
your kid has annoying
group projects that happen
during the school day
that you don't hear about
because by the time they get
home, they're either over it
or they've complained to their friends.
Under pandemic conditions,
you can run into your
teenager in the kitchen
when they just finished
an annoying group project,
and you're gonna get the full download.
So there is complaining,
there's heightened complaining,
but I don't want parents to
take all of the complaining
as though it's coming from a zero start.
It's higher and higher
for both pandemic reasons
and also just logistics of pandemics.
That totally makes sense.
And your comment about asking,
do you need my help or not?
I think applies to emotional things,
but also I know that
learning itself is hard
and kids can get in a place
just in working through
what they're supposed to be learning,
where they're struggling.
And in the educational psychology world,
we talk about productive struggle
and that that can actually
help people learn.
But if parents are seeing that,
how should they react to that?
And how do they figure out
when to help and when not to?
- Well for you to give
parents the gift of the idea
of productive struggle
is such a good first step
because as parents, we
know our kids so well,
and if they are doing school
like right over there next to you,
you can sense, even if
they're not saying anything,
you can sense when they
are starting to feel
tense or frustrated.
And as a parent, that makes
the parent uncomfortable.
I'm a parent who has a
kid doing school at home.
It makes me uncomfortable.
And so then of course we
want to step in and help.
Help.
Sometimes we think we're
stepping in to help the kid.
I will confess that I have
sometimes felt compelled to do it
because it's bothering me.
Like, I want to make it stop
so that I can focus on
what I need to focus on.
And my kid's discomfort
is a distraction for me,
so I want to make a stop.
Not because I think my kiddo needs it,
but because I sort of selfishly want it.
So the first step is to recognize
that learning is grappling,
and that kids getting
frustrated and struggling along
is often when learning happens.
And like you mentioned, teachers know this
and teachers develop the
capacity to tolerate,
and in fact, encourage
struggle in the classroom.
And so that idea of taking the guidance
around emotional wellbeing
and transferring it over
to academic wellbeing
to say, give parents a language,
to say something like,
are you doing okay with that struggle?
Do you need any support
around that struggle?
But not even to try to
get rid of the struggle,
or mostly just to bite our tongues
until a kiddo maybe sends up a flag.
But that's hard.
It's really easy to say, hard to do.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And I know it's hard too
if you're a parent who's
trying to work over here
and your kid's on the computer over here.
Having them know when
they can ask questions
and when it's okay to kind of jump in
as opposed to when you're
in the middle of doing
homeroom session, or whatever that may be.
I think it's another piece
that I've talked about
can be helpful for parents as well,
to kind of give their kids a plan
for what to do when they need help,
and so they know what to do.
- Absolutely.
- We are getting some.
Go ahead.
- I've sometimes encouraged
families under normal conditions
to actually have a list
of things kids can do
when they feel stuck.
Because for me, the big
challenges in school
are getting started and
managing when stuck.
And so it's really helpful to,
I've had kids put a Post-it
note next to their homework
of all of the options
for when they get stuck.
Move on to something else,
ask the teacher for more
instruction, phone a friend.
I mean, there's lots of
things that kids can do
and we can articulate those,
give kids lots of options,
brainstorm options when
they're not doing their work.
So that the first outlet isn't necessarily
the parent rescuing or the
kid asking for parent help.
- Fantastic.
So we are getting some good questions in
from Facebook and YouTube.
Let me take one of those.
From Facebook, Rosa Ballenger asks,
how do you get your kid motivated
when they're not turning in assignments?
What's the best approach to handle that?
Okay, so there's two pieces in there.
One is motivation.
The other is not turning in assignments.
Those are two different topics.
Let's start with the not
turning in assignments.
I think one of the real
challenges in parenting
is to tolerate kids having
to sort it out with their teachers.
And in my experience, if
parents don't rescue kids
and kids have to face the
music with their teachers,
and I trust teachers.
By and large they handle this really well
and really effectively.
Usually kids don't continue
to make that mistake
if they've had to really
have it out with the teacher.
And so if the parent can't stand it,
they might email the teacher and say,
I am well aware that
she's behind on her work.
I'm gonna leave it to you to figure out
what you think needs to be done here
or to give her the
consequences that is coming.
One thing when I have gotten
to be with groups of kids
in person is I'll sometimes
have them write notes of things
they want me to tell their parents.
So I visited schools and I'm like,
what do you want your parents to know?
And I am blown away by how
often I've had young people
write me a note saying, please tell them
to just let me deal with the
consequences of my choices.
Don't try to intervene.
And so kids can do that
and benefit from that.
Okay, then there's the
motivation question,
which for me right now in the pandemic
is like the million dollar question
because motivation is low.
And it's not that motivation
is high all the time
under normal conditions.
It's that it's lower now
because kids are not caught
up in the current of school.
They're not alongside
their friends doing work
they might not really feel like doing.
They're not being pushed
along by encouragement
in person from their teachers
in the same ways they might be used to.
So the challenges of motivation
that are always present
in education are now laid,
I think, more bare by the pandemic.
And I think that it lets
us have a conversation
that's probably long overdue
about motivation in school.
And the short on that conversation,
and then Kristen, I'll let you ask me
which direction you want to go with this.
The short on that is that I don't think
we're really honest
with kids about the fact
that a lot of really
high-functioning students
and high-functioning adults
sometimes need rewards to get work done.
I think we've sort of made it seem like
you shouldn't need that
or only sort of the lesser students
require that kind of support.
- Absolutely.
I know for myself that sometimes
when I have to write a
piece, write an article,
I say, okay, if I write this page,
I can have this Hershey's
Kiss as a reward.
So how do you think about,
what are appropriate rewards
and how can we best use
them to help kids succeed?
- Well, let's take a zoom
out and then zoom back in.
So the language we tend to
use in education for rewards
is extrinsic motivation,
that you're doing it
because somebody's giving you something.
It's a grade or money or chocolate,
I'm right with you on the chocolate.
For me, it's coffee.
For me, it is getting to take
a lap around the block, walking.
I have a long list of rewards
that I give myself to do work at times.
So we call those extrinsic motivators
and they're in contrast
to intrinsic motivators,
which is basically, the kid
does it 'cause they love it.
Like, they just are totally fascinated
and drawn to the work.
So we have generally and understandably
put intrinsic motivation on a pedestal.
Like that's the ideal, that's
what we're working toward.
And I'm all for that idea.
I think all students should
come to all of their work
open to the idea that they
might find it fascinating.
I think all educators
should do what they can
to present work in a way that makes it
as fascinating as possible to
as many students as possible.
So when you have intrinsic
motivation on your side,
what you have is effortless attention.
There's nothing to it,
and that's fantastic.
It doesn't always happen.
So then you still need
a gear you can slip into
to get it done.
That's the extrinsic motivation gear.
There need not be any shame about having
to sometimes use that gear.
You use it.
I use it.
We love our work.
We're doing our favorite subject.
We're getting paid and
we still need that gear.
And so the first step I think
is to be honest with kids,
to say, that's okay that
you're not into the work.
It still needs to get done.
What's the play?
How are we gonna do it?
And I have been blown
away by the creativity
students are sharing with me
about how they're getting work done.
Students have been telling
me about YouTube study videos
that they pull up where
you can go on YouTube
and find videos of very studious
and thoughtful students, it seems,
working in libraries and
they turn on the video
and they work alongside
the person in the video.
I had a fabulous student tell me
that she makes time-lapse
videos of herself studying
and she does it to keep herself focused
because she wants to have
a good time-lapse video.
So she'll work at a 25
to 50 minute unit of work
uninterrupted so that she
could have a really funny
time-lapse video or a very
complete time-lapse video
to show her parents or her friends.
And she said, they're very funny.
I love the faces I make
when concentrating.
- Oh my gosh.
- Brilliant, brilliant.
So there's that.
There's also chocolate.
There's also getting to roll around
on the floor with the dog.
There's getting to take
a lap around the block
with a parent.
There is social media.
Work really hard for 25 minutes,
take five minutes to check everybody out
on whatever social
media platform you want.
It doesn't matter to me so
much what the reward is.
I think it's great when kids are creative.
I think it's great when
we make space for them
to come up with things we
would have never thought of.
What matters to me is we
remove the shame from it,
that there's no reason to feel embarrassed
about the gimmicks or hacks
if you need them to get the work done.
The work has to get done.
- That's fantastic.
And I love working with your kids
to decide what's rewarding to them.
So that's something that they value
and is important for them.
But yeah, that's fantastic.
I had heard of people doing
Zoom calls with each other
and just turning the
video on to work together
as they're doing, as a
way to just keep connected
with each other, so all kinds of ideas.
- Absolutely, or just if you're lonely.
So another option is
for the parent to say,
do you want me to come work alongside you?
I can clear my email all day long.
I can clear it next to you.
When I was in graduate school,
I mean, I have great discipline
and I love my subject
and I love what I do.
And I am like the queen
of hacks to get work done.
And when I was in graduate school,
my best friend and I used
to sit across a table
from each other at a coffee shop
when we had 40 undergraduate
papers to grade,
and we played this game
where we could only speak to each other
after we'd each graded five papers.
And so we would plow
through five, talk for 10,
plow through five.
We got done in probably four hours
what if I had been left to my
own devices in my apartment
would have taken me to the whole weekend.
And those are the conversations
that grownups are not having with kids
and that we owe kids, and
they're left with this sense of,
oh, the good students feel like doing it
or some day my motivation will show up.
I'm stuck till then.
That is not a helpful
way to try to do school.
- Absolutely.
Fantastic.
Let's take another question from Facebook.
We have a Maya Aplig.
I'm gonna kill this last name, Giock.
And again, apologize for that last name.
She asks, I have a 13-year-old
son that is screen-obsessed.
I have struggled to
set healthy boundaries.
He's seeing a psychologist,
but I would love to hear
your advice might be
for setting healthy
screen-time boundaries.
- Okay, so these are my
rules and they are pandemic
and also pre and post-pandemic.
These are my general rules
for kids and screens.
First rule, what really
matters first and foremost
in my mind is what's on the screen.
What screens deliver is such a wide range.
So school is fabulous.
Good for kids, fantastic.
Educational TV, all for it.
Banal TV.
If kids need a break and just a time
to sort of relax and rest.
Happy socializing with their friends.
Kids need to socialize.
Screens are where that's at right now.
So there's all sorts of good
stuff that happens on screens.
I'm okay with hours of
good stuff on screens.
That's what a lot of kids
are doing these days.
I'm not okay with five
seconds of porn, right?
Or super violent, yucky stuff.
So first and foremost was on
the screens can't be yucky.
Can't be something that
kids should not be seeing,
and that doesn't get articulated enough.
So that's the first guardrail.
The second guardrail is that
screens cannot get in the way
of what is necessary for
healthy development in children.
Okay, so here's my list.
This is my short list.
We can add to this list.
First and foremost, sleep.
Sleep, sleep, sleep.
Elementary school kids
need 11 hours a night.
Middle schoolers need 10 hours a night.
High schoolers need nine hours a night.
This is actually happening
more than it usually does
because kids aren't commuting
or unfortunately doing afterschool stuff,
but sleep and screens are mortal enemies.
I don't think screens
should be in bedrooms.
I totally get it, that some
families don't have the space
to do otherwise.
I totally get it, that some
kids are having to do school
in their bedrooms.
Understand completely.
It should come out at night.
So sleep.
Physical activity.
Kids should be up and moving around.
We have to work harder
to make that happen.
It's worth it.
Face-to-face interactions.
Reading people's faces,
picking up social cues.
Screens should not get in the way of that.
Screens should not get in
the way of focused work.
Kids should not have screens
interrupting their ability
to read with focus,
even do one thing on a screen with focus.
Sometimes kids are doing like schoolwork
and then popping over to their phone
to check their social media, not okay.
And screens should not get in the way
of being helpful around the house,
around the community, all of the above.
So my advice to parents is
decide what matters to you
and then protect it from screens.
And be for those things,
not against screens.
And then the goal of course
is to have so much activity
and so much time helping
out around the house
and so much excellent sleep
that the time left for
screens is minimized.
But then the time on
screens is spent doing stuff
that actually makes kids' lives better
or gives them some relaxation.
Doesn't do any harm.
- That's sounds very
actionable and useful.
Thank you.
I have another question coming
in about prioritization,
like in that way.
So from Facebook, Catherine Terry says,
my son is really struggling to engage
with virtual school and get his work done.
I know he's emotionally
exhausted, as we all are.
I feel like beating up
on him about academics
is not as important as
helping him navigate
and take care of his mental health
and would love to know your thoughts.
- I agree completely.
My mantra for the pandemic is this.
The goal is actually not to see
how productive and
disciplined everybody can be.
The goal is for all of us
to get to the other side
of this emotionally intact.
So there may be moments
where you feel like
I'm gonna choose my kid's
wellbeing over the perfection,
or even maybe the completion
of that assignment.
I think that is a fair call right now.
The other thing though
that's a good half step is
to just go ahead and empathize with him
about how hard the school piece is.
I think sometimes when parents
feel like they can't fix it,
they feel like they're helpless.
You're not.
There is a space between
fixing and doing nothing.
And that is the empathy
place where we just say,
buddy, I get it.
I cannot imagine how hard it
must be to do school this way.
It's like, school is all
vegetables, no dessert.
This is no fun.
I totally get it.
That will help your son out.
The other thing that I think
we cannot overdo right now
is just admiring how
well our kids are doing
in spite of what's being asked.
I think parents should be
saying constantly to their kids,
you are doing a really good job with this.
I see how hard you are trying.
I am so impressed with how much attention
you're giving this, given
how kind of dry or distant
or disconnected it feels.
I see it.
I'm impressed.
Way to go.
I mean, there is no
limit on that right now.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And when we talked about motivation,
we know that if you feel
like you're failing,
you're gonna be even less
motivated to do something.
And if you feel like
you're having some success,
even if it's small successes,
that gives you more motivation
to keep trying and keep
doing what you're doing.
So I think that positive reinforcement
helps communicate that.
All right, I've got another question
that I know everyone is asking,
thinking about how kids are struggling
because they are lacking
now the social interaction
that they usually have.
Do you have any suggestions
about how we can bring
some of that experience to kids?
How we can help them feel
connected to their peers?
- Well, most kids, a lot of kids
are using social media to stay connected.
It's interesting how quickly
we've sort of decided
we're okay with social media,
which I actually, I am on that train.
Kids should see their friends.
They should get to socialize in person.
What this means is that parents
probably have to supervise.
And that's the challenge
because parents' plates
are already so full.
They're trying to run homes,
do jobs outside the home sometimes,
and also sort of monitor school.
Parents are down to their last minute.
Parents were spread very thin.
And the idea of now having to
make some sort of organized
socializing happen where
an adult can be available
is just one more layer on top of that.
And yet kids do need to see
their friends in person.
What I would say to
parents to make it easier,
see if you can make a routine.
Have a standing play date with a kid
that your kid gets along with.
Maybe trade off supervision
duties with that parent,
but don't go week to week
trying to figure this out,
'cause that just takes too much energy.
But what I would say, and
this is important and helpful
for kids to hear, when psychologists say
everybody needs lots of social support,
which we do right now,
I think people often hear everybody needs
a big and busy social life,
which is not what we mean.
We actually mean something quite specific
in terms of social support.
And this is true at all
ages, for kids and parents.
We mean everybody needs somebody
to tell their worries to.
Everybody needs somebody they
can tell their secrets to.
And everybody needs a person or a group
who helps them to feel
connected and accepted.
So some adults get this
entirely from their partner.
Some kids get this from one best friend.
Some kids are getting the worries piece
covered by telling their siblings,
the secrets thing covered
by telling their friends
they go to camp with out of state,
and the connected and accepted
thing, one good friend,
or they actually really like their folks,
that they've got those bases covered.
So when I'm talking with
kids about their worries
about their social lives right now,
I like to run down that list,
worries, secrets, connected and accepted.
See if they are checking
all of those boxes.
If they're not, that's
something we want to get on.
If they are, I then say
to them, that's your cake.
That's what you really need.
You've got those bases covered.
Everything else is icing.
And it's useful both in truly evaluating
the scale of the problem,
which is often smaller than it looked.
And also in terms of reassuring kids
that they're doing it right.
Because of course they're
looking on social media
or they're aware, it
feels like everybody else
is hanging out all the time
and it's greatly reassuring to
them to get concrete guidance
around what's really necessary here.
- Your guidance has been
so helpful and useful.
For folks that want to hear more of this,
I know you have a book out in 2020.
Can you tell us a little bit about that
and what folks can expect from that?
So I have two New York Times bestsellers,
one published in 2016 and one 2019.
The one from 2016 is Untangled,
which is about normal
development in adolescent girls,
though 80% of it applies to boys.
The one from 2019 is about the epidemic
of stress and anxiety in girls,
which seems like way too timely now.
Again, 80% of that applies to boys.
But I also just launched a podcast
with my colleague Reenan Ninan
and it's called Ask Lisa:
The Psychology of Parenting.
It comes out every Tuesday morning.
It's 25 minutes long.
And every week we take a
question from a parent.
You can also send questions to me.
If you go to my website,
there's information
about how to send in questions
and we tackle whatever is top
of mind for parents right now,
because what we're finding is
the pandemic moves so quickly.
The pressures on parents change so rapidly
that once a week lets
us really being nimble
in response to what is weighing on parents
and hard at home right now.
- That sounds great.
Thank you so much for offering
all this support to parents
as we all try to get through this.
We really appreciate your
coming to join us today.
So I will, from here, just
close and let folks know
that if they want more discussion
about motivation topics,
tomorrow we have a
webinar that is happening
at 4:00 p.m. Pacific, at 7:00 Eastern,
and there's a link there that
you can sign up for that.
And of course we will
have homeroom tomorrow.
Hopefully Sal will have
recovered and can join us.
Our guest tomorrow is doctor
or Superintendent Austin Buetner
from the Los Angeles
Unified School District.
And so we'll be talking about
some of the challenges faced
from the district perspective.
Thank you all for joining
us and have a good day.